Airaid Sirens sounded in Kiev at the
start of the EU Ukraine Summit a meeting
as much about symbolism as talks EU
leaders side by side with Ukraine's
president in Kiev a show of the Block's
support for Ukraine and a message to
Moscow that despite its attempts keeves
looking West Ukraine wants to join the
EU its candidacy was accepted last year
and it won succession negotiations to be
fast-tracked but EU leaders say that
fulfilling the many conditions required
may take years
there are no rigid timelines
but there are goals that you have to
reach reforms for example to improve a
situation in the candidate country to
then reach the accession negotiations
and the accession itself
your determination to forge ahead is
impressive
talks also focused on Military Support
for Ukraine Vladimir zielinski once
again urging Western leaders to send
Keith more weapons
if weapons deliveries are accelerated
namely long-range weapons we will not
only not withdraw from bakmut we will
begin to deoccupy donbass which has been
occupied since 2014.
the EU says it will continue sending
military and humanitarian Aid to Ukraine
and will train 30 000 Ukrainian soldiers
it also pledged money for demining and
reconstruction in the country as well as
a new round of sanctions against Russia
the 10th package is on its way
we have the AIM to have it in place by
the 24th of February it has a volume of
round about 10 billion euros it's a
massive pro package again it was the
first time that an EU Summit had been
held in a country in Wartime although
there were differences during this
Summit over the speed of kiev's EU
membership process EU leaders agreed
that Ukraine is fighting this war
against Russia not only for itself but
for the whole of Europe Natasha Butler
Al Jazeera Kiev